le rapport commence au 4 mars 2021 avec
notre invité
booba mon ami mon frère
que j'aime il le sait avec qui on est
comme ça
l'art comme nous avec plein gré parce
qu'il portait une marque que nous en a
et que nous en avons parlé
ce n'est que le début à vous demander de
regarder les images de ce premier fort
c'est comme ça vous le remettez le
forfait du secteur souligne aussi tu
m'as mis hier sur l'émission là-bas
c'est la même personne qui maximise les
incroyables hba1c croyable j'étais une
capture d'écran j'ai je le veux pas
jouer sur deux jeunes intérieurs
[Rires]
on a bien sûr foot et la marque enfin le
30 septembre 2021 de fait nous sont
reprochés d'une part je portais une
veste de la marque qui commence par
balles
finie
la collection
de poires d'autre part je portais de
manière ostentatoire mes lunettes
regardez les images du second délit
je remercie mes amis un devis ce très
beau ça
c'est pas net et la situation se tend à
nous amène à demander des explications
vous prendre septembre toujours nous
recevions isabelle saporta
saporta
on embrasse isabelle saporta c'est un
petit peu le la paire en espagne
les portes
et mon éditrice nous faisions quelques
allusions aux livres nous avons fait
ensemble grosse erreur
grave erreur que diaby est partout
rebelote le 7 octobre et cette fois
encore l'art comme nous pointent du
doigt qu'à regarder
on va revenir sur les articles et une de
magazines qui ont été publiées à mon
sujet c'est un dur c'est vrai qu'on voit
là avec la sortie du livre on n'a pas
droit de faire de la promo d'ailleurs
pour le lis donc on n'en parle pas trop
c'est vrai que la sortie du livre voilà
voilà vous verrez dans le livre c'est
vrai que je parle de tout ça et je dis
voilà il m'arrive pas d'échangés parfois
avec le avec le président c'est vrai que
je suis le mène campagne en fait je moi
je ne pensais pas avoir à faire à autant
de mépris social concernant cyril
hanouna et je trouve que c'est vraiment
ahurissant c'est moins une question sur
un mec à part libre syrie va déjà mieux
oui le vôtre et dans le coffre de la
voiture figurez vous ah oui en attente
on attend on attend de finir les
livraisons je me mets que tout de suite
cyril hanouna
menace les chroniqueurs de ne pas les
faire rentrer sur le plateau s'ils
n'achètent pas son livre
on intègre à puce et astrium
et enfin
une chroniqueuse
qui a désiré garder l'anonymat
nous appellerons entre nous kelly
elle aussi a été mise en demeure
26 octobre 2021 porter une tenue
couverte de marque
regardez l'horreur en images
kelly est ce que vous ça vous dérange
pas mais pas du tout en fait moi j'ai
répondu oui parce que oui c'est ringard
on adore ce soir un gars c'est là comme
savoir à quoi là là là elle aurait dû
être comme ça pour moi c'est à dire ça
aurait été voilà c'est la femme floutés
j'ai donc pu m'adresser à vous mes
chroniqueurs mes amis mes frères
pour benjamin je dirais même que mon
poto gros lolos
[Rires]
dois je me rendre aux autorités suisses
coupables ou non coupables et si oui
pourquoi je vous donnerai mon avis est
ensuite
parti
gilles verdez vous n'êtes pas coupable
j'ai regardé les textes qui sont précis
d'abord la référence à des biens mais
pas systématiquement équivalente à de la
pub clandestine et là ils ont pris tous
les indices parce qu'il parle d'un
disent ils ont pris des indices ils
n'ont pas de fait et ils ont tiré à
chaque fois d'une manière éhontée
subjective pour vous accusez et dernier
point il ya un point qui me sensibilise
particulièrement booba ils disent
explicitement dans les règlements que
quand c'est un sportif qui l'affichent a
tenu il a tout à fait le droit comme au
tour de france la buba à une marque qui
lui est cher c'est un artiste c'est
exactement le même cas de figure on
exemple le tour de france on accuse
booba vous n'êtes pas coupable c'est une
injustice énorme
je suis coupable moi ça me choque parce
que je ne mets jamais de marc
personnellement déjà
[Rires]
moi je trouve ça honteux ce que vous
avez fait cyril imaginer c'est comme si
moi je faisais la pub de ma marque
genton streetwear la nouvelle marque des
vagues magnifiques et celle ci est
disponible sur mon site internet
twitter.com avec 10% pour les premiers
utilisateurs trouve ça choquant
même film mais en fait il ya tous les
soirs des émissions donc forcément dans
votre dressing la marque n'est pas de la
marque puis en règle générale quand vous
avez de la marque vous êtes aussi
scotché de partout de s'assurer que je
veux respecter vraiment le cas le dress
code alors je n'ai pas j'avoue que ce
n'est pas toujours respectée oui mais
bon j'avoue j'avoue que je n'ai pas tout
de respecter il ya des règles et je
tiens à le dire le nouveau président de
l'art comme il est vraiment sympa on
peut discuter avec lui tout ça est ce
que avant il y avait un gars c'est vrai
qu'il pouvait pas intégrer donc tout ce
qu'on disait lui il est il est juste ça
veut dire que c'est vrai que voilà après
je vous dirais l'histoire c'est qu'on
était dénoncée comme à chaque fois on a
été dénoncé par des petits camarades
donc moi clair comme fasse son travail
je comprends tout à fait et franchement
je respecte il ya des règles elles
doivent être les mêmes pour tout le
monde ça franchement le jeudi et et je
vous dis vraiment recoller vers maistre
qui lobe le président il est pas pour
l'autre nous il fait voilà il est il est
plutôt y il fait pareil pour tout le
monde mais c'est vrai que qu'on nous ait
dénoncé c'est énorme ça il ya des mecs
thuram c'est ça oui yanina
c'est quoi alors bon je dirais d'abord
coupable de beauté
et aux cantons a un corps comme le vôtre
vous ne devrait pas le droit de
s'habiller je passe
mon people oui à trois fois par semaine
le court après et vous force à les
utiliser pour les mettre en valeur et
qui d'autre pour les mettre en valeur
aujourd'hui que le petit génie du paf le
mannequin de la télé la télé voilà merci
mais je dois dire aussi que pour avoir
des jeunes et une fois avec le directeur
général de cette chaîne francs capitaux
il avait dit lors du non mais ça a été
plus difficile à exploiter on dit des
jeunes et il me dit j'ai un vrai souci
est ce que tu peux dire à cyril
d'arrêter de mettre des marques visibles
on va avoir des problèmes à la fin ouais
pourquoi julie franchetto penses tu
vraiment que j'ai pu me dire quelque
chose à cyril
toi tu n'y arrives pas
vous n'avez qu'a tenté à l'époque le
message oui mais j'ai vraiment vous êtes
non coupable j'espère enfin merci ben
moi pour moi je suis coupable vous moi
je vous mets non je ne connais pas votre
nom
pourquoi vous alors d'abord j'apprends
qu'il ya des gens chez l'art comme the
study on les aime beaucoup et comme tu
as dit mais d'abord ils sont payés pour
rester chez eux attendre qu'on balance
pour venir apprennent leur métier pas
les prévenir faut qu'il le voit
ici et pourquoi quand je regarde
d'autres chaînes je vois des marques
monde en série et abbaoui valeurs là qui
a bâti 17 mois je n'ai jamais jamais il
a raison il a raison d'échapper à ce que
bien sûr il
te plait pas français on a regardé
mais souvent on va être mise en demeure
pour
maltraitance de la langue française
pour les marques on sera tranquille de
quoi sur les animals jours d autres
scènes sur les animaux tu as vu quoi
t'as vu des chemins de la gueule emma
des chevals j'ai vu des animals vers
vous avez pas vu vous
des crocos fait plein de trucs un réseau
de chaînes ont dit rien et ici parce que
toi tu mets des trucs avec des scotchs
c'est ridicule autant rien mais il faut
que j ai marqué la cote temps énorme il
ya un moment
tu dois citer d'autres marques
fendi
sportswear sportswear chic et les bas
c'est un film est fini et nike d'accord
mais
soit je pense que la règle elle est
complètement obsolète ridicule et
grotesque comprend les téléspectateurs
pour des abrutis parce que là vous avez
mis en gros un bout de scotch sur votre
virgules bien sûr au monde sait ce que
c'est un bon j'ai pas mis la vie rurale
à la devil may en tournée vous vous
foutez toute la merde
[Musique]
coaché mais ont très bien que c'est la
virgule ancien les trois bandes on life
ockrent elle a eu trois bandes janvier
avec les réseaux sociaux nous décrions
dit j'aime bien ce côté là mais hier
c'est quoi la marque et tout ça donc en
fait on sait on devine art et on prend
les gens pour des abrutis et franchement
il faut changer cette règle qui est
complètement obsolète à mon sens c'est
ça n'aura en fait dans vos accuse de
publicité clandestine dans vos réussir
alors je tiens à ce qu'il exauce pour
qu'il y ait une pub faut qu'on ait été
mariée et rémunérés pour vous est offert
les fringues je peux attester que cyril
achète l'ensemble de toute sa garde robe
lilas qu'il a quelques cadeaux mais on
en a 90 présent en tout cas des marques
vous prenez ça repart le soir même et
ses passagers sont blessés voilà et donc
essayer le jeu de fringues donc en fait
ce cas précis ça peut pas de la plus pro
d2 paraît non mais ça c'est vrai ça j'ai
honte de le dire c'est évidemment oui
valérie non mais ce que dit géraldine
est tout à fait juste sévère fou c'est
une règle qui est obsolète parce que
c'est une loi qui pouvait tenir à
l'époque il n'y avait pas les réseaux
sociaux or aujourd'hui il suffit de même
même si vous ne vous exprimer pas même
si on ne voit pas la marque il ya
maintenant des applications où vous en
photo on la met dans shazam démarre et
on vous dit pas voir ce qu'ils portaient
ces têtes elles marquent donc voilà ce
qu'on peut savoir ce qu'il faut
combattre
et par ailleurs pour pour revenir sur
des choses très précises par exemple
booba vous n'êtes pas responsable de ce
qu'il dit au moment où il le dit vous
avez pas faire rétropédaler en octobre
voilà ça c'est en direct parce que le
reconnaître que dans le cas de booba qui
est votre ami est le mien aussi et je
n'adore mais vous vous portez des
marques qui nous appartiennent pas dans
quelque part on fait de la vue brouillée
n'est rien si vous n'êtes pas
actionnaire oui mais pas quand c'est un
habitué qui vient c'est sa marque il
l'assure vent simple même si l'ancien
président a dit
qu'il veut oui s'ils doivent s'ils ont
la chance
que ça commence
ici c'est parce que c'est leur chalet du
monde l'afrique est à côté a bien sûr
les sur les
galas mais moi je le vois
vous avez façon et je le dis je ne ferai
plus jamais de pub clandestine de toute
ma vie vraiment pour
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai plus de problèmes
a vraiment voilà